[MUSIC]
This past summer,
I landed the internship of a lifetime.
No, it wasn't that amazing business
development internship at AirBnB.
Or that super sexy product
management role at Amazon.
Or even that really cool secret project
at unnamed startup in self mode.
It was an introjapat Costco.
Yes, Costco wholesale, the place that
you might remember as a concrete jungle,
littered with oversized
red shopping carts.
Or maybe the place that gives
away free food samples and
is featured in Fresh Off the Boat
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or maybe you just remember it as this.
>> And you might be thinking to yourself,
why would a former McKinsey consultant,
former VC investor And
current student at a business school
in the heart of Silicon Valley.
Want to move to Issaquah,
Washington to work for a large and
old school company like Costco?
Well as it turns out, most of us in this
room have been chasing the next
sexy startup, the next big unicorn.
But what about the companies that have
endured and existed for years on end?
I like to think of these as
the rhinos of the business world.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They're definitely not sexy,
they certainly have more wrinkles,
they're slower moving.
They're more methodical but
they have have thicker skin,
greater strength and more wisdom.
And they may just be a little bit more
real then their mythological counterparts.
Indeed, my summer opened my eyes to
just how wonderful these rhinos can be.
The lessons I learned in humility,
in entrepreneurship and
in impact,
are ones that I will never forget.
Lesson number one, working for
a rhino is humbling.
My alarm clock at blared
at 3:15 in the morning,
I rolled over, I hit the snooze button.
And I thought to my self,
[SOUND] I could definitely use at
least a couple more hours of sleep.
How could I possibly be this tired when
it was only my second day on the job.
I made it outta bed, clocked into the
warehouse right at four in the morning,
grabbed a pallet jack,
and reported for duty.
Over the course of that morning my
hands got sore from moving what
seemed like endless amounts of Campbell's
soup from one palate to the next.
My back started to ache
as I swept the floors,
making sure that our isles were showtime
ready for opening at 10 in the morning.
It was the hardest work I had ever down,
and yet it only paid $20 an hour.
I often thought to myself,
what am I doing here?
I couldn't help but
compare myself to my peers,
who I imagined sitting at a desk
building fancy models in Excel.
Or creating beautiful Powerpoint
presentations filled with interesting
strategies.
And yet here I was, I had a hard time
seeing the value of sweeping floors.
Or ringing customers up at the cash
registers and of making food in the deli.
But then I met Joe.
Joe had been with the company for
the last 12 years.
You couldn't miss him with
the six foot two stature.
His baggy sweatpants and
a backwards Raiders cap on at all times.
You always knew that he was on shift
because you could hear his hip-hop and
rap music blasting from his
radio at 4:30 in the morning.
And as I got to know him, I learned that
Joe didn't really know what he wanted to
do with this life, but
he loved his job at Costco.
He told me, the company's been
really good to me, it rewards me for
something I'm actually pretty good at.
So maybe one day, I'll apply to be
a supervisor, and I'll earn my red vest.
And then maybe eventually,
I could be a manager.
Joe's story was just one of
the many I heard this summer,
that reminded me that my fellow warehouse
workers were each trying to achieve their
own version of the American dream.
They might not have gone to the same
schools as us, or worked for
the same companies as us.
But they too had an ambition to create
a life of meaning for themselves.
Whether it was Nicki's love of her 4 AM
shift that enabled her to pick up her
daughter after school.
Or Alex's drive and determination
to work his way through college.
They were all incredibly hardworking,
dedicated and damn good at their jobs.
Now that's pretty humbling.
Lesson number two,
you can be entrepreneurial and at a rhino.
I remember I was out of breath
because I had been sprinting across
150,000 square feet of
concrete warehouse floor.
A customer had asked me if we still had
the sleep science mattress in stock.
In pursuit of her question,
I first ran over to the supervisor
to ask her if she knew.
And then I ran over to the stocker who
typically worked the furniture department.
And then finally I ran back to
the office to check our AS400 system,
only to come up with the lousy answer.
I'm so sorry ma'am our system
shows that we have one, but
we don't know where it is.
And I thought to myself,
there must be a better way to
get this kind of information.
And so I embarked on a journey
to build them a mobile app,
that would let them see real-time
inventory levels right on their phones.
Now let's not get carried away here,
I am by no means a coder but
I'm pretty good at using Google.
And so I hacked together what we might
generously call a minimum viable product.
>> [LAUGH]
>> When I showed Tyler the merchandising
manager the app, he was stoked.
He asked if we could augment it,
add more data to it, show more dashboards.
And pretty soon I had a bunch of team
members come up to me to ask me how to
download it and if they could use it.
So I identified a customer pinpoint,
I designed a customer centric solution,
I built an MVP and
I pivoted on that product.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And no, I wasn't working for a unicorn.
Who says you have to work at one
to be an entrepreneur anyways?
Lesson number three?
Rhinos shape communities.
You've probably never heard of
a town called Fremont, Nebraska, but
it's about an hour outside of Omaha.
We were there visiting
Costco's construction site for
their poultry processing plant
that had just broken ground.
Freemont is pretty desolate,
has one main street with a couple
of stop lights that hang on a wire.
A few mom-and-pop shops,
one bar in town for all the locals.
The only restaurant I recognized
was a Buffalo Wild Wings.
Over the course of a three-night trip,
we eat there twice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I remember sitting in
the trailer on the construction site.
And I was talking to Jonathan,
the plant manager and
he was explaining to me the org chart.
And I was shocked at the team
size they were proposing.
As of April 2019, this plant would
create 800 new jobs in Freemont alone.
I was stunned.
I knew that rhinos had impact.
Whether it was Costco's title as
the largest organic retailer in the US or
the largest seller of USDA
choice in prime beef.
I knew they were big, but
what I hadn't fully realized is just
how much they impact local communities.
They create employment, they create
opportunity, they create an economy.
A few weeks ago, a CEO of a rhino
came to the GSP and asked us.
Don't you want to do something
more than just sell ad space?
Now maybe that's exactly
what you want to do or
it's been your life's
passion to start a company.
To be a management consultant,
to join a big tech firm.
I'm not suggesting you shouldn't, but
what I am suggesting is that you take
a moment to consider what you might
want to be able to achieve at a rhino.
They're not for the faint of heart,
they don't offer free-flowing food or
nap pods, Starwood points or
shuttle buses.
But they do offer a platform for humility,
for entrepreneurship and impact.
So while you're dreaming of what it might
be like to work at the next big unicorn
that has yet to exist, don't forget about
their long lost cousins, the rhinos.
I'm excited to announce that I
will be rejoining Costco for
their very official MBA rotational
program starting next fall.
And of one.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Don't get me wrong,
it terrifies me that I'm not joining
a rocket ship or the big three, or
fund to funds.
I'm scared that I'm zagging when everyone
else around us seems to be zigging.
But I know that for
me joining a rhino is my best possible
opportunity to change lives,
change organizations and
change the world.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]